what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back again with another Avengers
versus X-men fight and this time it's
Captain America versus Gambit and I know
some of you guys might kind of be like
why would Gambit be able to go
toe-to-toe with Captain America Gambit's
one of the best fighters in Marvel
Comics and it's one of the elements of
his character that's constantly slept on
so one of the things to kind of keep in
mind coming out of the last video that
we did is again much like what we
covered before it was Hope Summers the
Phoenix Force but basically it's the
idea that the Avengers are afraid that
this girl will gain Godlike power right
that Hope Summers will become the
Phoenix she'll lose her mind just like
Gan gray did and then in turn basically
attack most all of humanity now a little
more explanation based on what we talked
about yesterday the reason why there's
this biggest fear here really comes from
Bishop and the reason for that is yes
Hope Summers is the first mutant born
out of House of M right the first mutant
born since Scarlet Witch took away
everybody's Powers but what's so
important about this is that the
character of Bishop comes from a future
where Hope Summers had initiated a
conflict and wiped out like a million
humans in virtually no time at all that
basically led to Days of Future Past and
then eventually humanity and mutants
banded together in order to throw off
the Sentinel program and then take Earth
back you kind of saw a loose Alliance
that sort of thing but ever since Hope
Summers arrived on the scene going from
Messiah complex into Messiah War back at
the time this story was written it was
really an attempt by Bishop to basically
find and kill hope before she could
become this just kind of monster that
would lay waste to everything and so
that's really where the biggest root of
the Avengers fear comes from that Hope
Summers will lay waste to the Earth
itself and basically kill everybody and
so again much like Iron Man Who was on
the hunt for hope during our coverage of
his fight with Magneto which if you
didn't see that make sure you click the
link to the video at the end of this
video and you'll see the whole thing
this has Captain America looking for
Hope Summers as well only to come across
the path of Gambit now again Gambit is a
prodigious fighter in Marvel Comics is
he on the same level of Captain America
not really kind of he's able to hold his
own here Captain America is more Adept
at different styles of martial arts
Gambit is adept at things like Cate
right like French kickboxing things like
that but he's ridiculously capable of
that kind of stuff whether he's better
than Captain America it's something like
French kickboxing I'm not entirely sure
and even you'll see over the course of
this fight Captain America Blends a
multitude of fighting styles to himself
but then this is going to end like quick
fast and in a hurry and you're going to
see just how capable Captain America is
so the first thing to know is that
Captain America is not really here to
try to like destroy Gambit right that's
not really the goal of any of the
Avengers they're not looking to kill the
X-Men and even if they wanted to they
probably couldn't right but Captain
America does the first thing that you
would expect right like where Gambit
literally just throws playing cards at
Captain America kind of his opening move
and the thing that he's most well known
for it does create a series of
explosions Captain America of course
isn't really taken out by that but he
grabs his shield and then throws it at
Gambit this is one of the coolest things
right because Gambit Dodges out of the
way right that's really based more on
his ability with acrobatics than
anything else right because between his
bow staff and the two or three different
forms of martial arts he knows as well
as his acrobatic abilities the guy's
ridiculously capable in fighting but he
grabs Captain America's shield midair he
says says I think I've managed to snag
the old man's attention after all I
suppose you want this back he charges up
the shield of Captain America and throws
it back at him which is just one of the
coolest moments that I think ever came
out of Avengers versus X-men and the
thing here is that the whole time that
Captain America is in this fight with
Gambit he's talking to Iron Man and that
really goes to the nature of Captain
America's fighting abilities but not
just his fighting abilities his battle
strategy and again while Captain America
isn't really overly powerful or anything
that's really what makes him so capable
the fact that he's able to kind of do
multiple things at the same time and
give each of them a sort of degree of
attention but again there's a difference
between fighting Captain America while
he's doing a few different things and
fighting Captain America while he's
Focus exclusively on you because in the
midst of this fight he says I'm sorry
Tony I'm getting some interference on
our Comm signal I'll wrap things up here
and then we can regroup and in the fight
between himself and Gambit of course
Gambit tries to use his bow stick that
kind of thing and then literally like
Captain America just like snaps it in
half plunges this guy against a tree and
then like Captain America ask him how
much time do we have left so again not
fully focusing on his fight with Gambit
but still able to hold his own against
this guy now Gambit has this amazing
response but here's one of the things
about Gambit that a lot of people don't
know he has a kind of hypnotic
suggestion there's a reason why Gambit
always got the girls in Marvel Comics
and there was a reason why it was so
frustrating that he couldn't get ROK
Gambit when it came to like any normal
person out there they like tell you to
do a thing and you would just kind of be
hypnotically suggested into doing it
it's not nearly on the same level as
someone like purp man or telepath or
something like that it's very very
subtle and it only works on the weakest
of Minds Captain America it won't work
against him at all it won't even begin
to work right he won't feel one bit not
even a little bit right like so it's
really kind of a useless ability here
but it is the reason why you see him
kind of taunting Captain America to a
degree and even saying things like
didn't your mama tell you it's Bad
Manners to ignore your company now the
cool thing here is that Gambit goes and
touches the chest of Captain America and
starts to light up his suit now Captain
America makes this comment which I do
want to talk about here for a second he
says come on Gambit we both know your
powers cannot charge Organics now
there's a reason why this comments made
by Captain America I don't recall
whether or not he actually was engaged
in the initial conflict but in Marvel
there's a character named new son right
now here's the thing Gambit as you know
him is not his most powerful form and in
fact Gambit gave up a huge significant
amount of his power at least at the
hands of Mr Sinister in order to gain
control over his abilities because it
wasn't something that he readily had the
ability to do he could do all kinds of
crazy stuff but he couldn't really
control his powers giving that up going
to Mr Sinister and having Sinister kind
of perform a labotomy of sorts gave
Gambit control over his abilities but
drastically reduced what he was capable
of new Sun didn't have that problem he
was Gambit from an alternate reality
this guy was so powerful that he was
able to wipe out whole planets right he
could literally just charge virtually
anything even without touching it and
blow it to Pieces organic material for
example was something that he could
detonate and Destroy and so where
Captain America makes the St statement
the response of Gambit is you're getting
slow a fish didn't make these scales
right they're just traditional scales
because Captain America's thought is
Gambit's going to try to blow him up
right like literally his skin but by
charging up his suit it sends him flying
and then Captain America comes out of
this Rubble incensed because Gambit gets
aarant right he was like one living
legend down for the count and then
Captain America's just standing there
and he was like cute trick Gambit you
have my undivided attention now and this
is when you find out what happens when
someone goes toe-to-toe with Captain
America and Captain America himself is
focused exclusively on you in the span
of four panels Gambit is crushed right
he throws his cards Captain America
blocks it with the shield charges Gambit
blocks his kick punches him in the face
and Gambit's done that's it it's that
fast right like it's it's crazy now
whether or not this is accurate given
the Mythos of Gambit that's kind of Up
For Debate and in fact this fight was
one that was very very contested by the
Marvel fan base specifically Gambit fans
they were like there's no way he would
have been taken out by Captain America
that quickly like that's just not going
to happen why didn't he ignite his bow
staff right there were a lot of
different things that he could have done
or at least the fans argue he could have
done but at the end of the day Gambit's
defeated by Captain America with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this to an end as always if you need to
get caught up on the last video that we
did make sure you click this link to the
playlist and and let me know down in the
comments section who do you think should
have actually won this fight but I will
catch you all later peace